le comité des médicaments à usage humain
confirme que le rapport risque bénéfice
reste positif est que le vaccin de
johnson and johnson est efficace pour
prévenir toute contamination koffi 19
c'était un feu vert attendu dans toute
l'europe comme les vaccins de pfizer
moderna et astrazeneca avant lui l'
agence européenne des médicaments a
validé ce mardi l'efficacité de celui de
johnson & johnson
le régulateur européen confirme
cependant un lien possible entre le
vaccin et de rares effets secondaires
graves observés chez cette passion aux
états unis car ce qu'est une enquête
poussée sur ces cas et d'autres indices
ont mené aux conclusions suivantes les
quais de caillots sanguins sont très
rares les effets secondaires rapportés
concernent majoritairement des femmes de
moins de 60 ans et apparaissent dans les
trois semaines suivant l'injection un
stade est vacciné ici là le m souhaite
continuer ses recherches tout en
informant les citoyens européens
une notice d'avertissement devra ainsi
accompagné le sérum nous sommes toujours
en relation avec les autorités
américaines
mais nous n'avons décelé aucun cas au
sein de l'union européenne
ce sont des effets secondaires rares il
est donc d'autant plus important
d'informer les patients pour que ces
derniers on reconnaisse les symptômes et
demande le cas échéant l'aide d'un
spécialiste
ce vaccin ne requiert qu'une seule
injection son entrée sur le marché
européen permettrait donc d'accélérer
les campagnes de vaccination en
attendant l'avis de la m
le laboratoire avait suspendu ses
livraisons en europe
son pdg s'est dit prêt à les reprendre
dès que possible
200 millions de doses doivent partir
pour l'union européenne la norvège et
l'islande
en france le ministère de la santé juge
ces doses indispensable pour atteindre
son objectif de 30 millions de primo
vacciner à la mi juin
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique le
vaccin johnson & johnson est toujours
suspendu l'autorité américaine des
médicaments doit se prononcer vendredi
sur la reprise des injections